[Music]
like smoke in the air and
everything techno techno music opening
That's so
exciting does it show up on the screen
does it look good you can see my
desktop my desktop consists mostly of
head shots of myself which is bad
because I have a puge ego and then AI
generated head shot of myself with
actual hair
this is uh the AI of me as an astronaut
apparently cool um we're very excited
that you all are here and I'm very happy
to be opening up um the festival today
uh this is pretty exciting stuff I will
admit I am a little bit jet lagged my
son and I came here uh just yesterday uh
in the middle seat in coach uh and uh
got in about 2:00 yesterday and then we
had that whole argument if you've ever
flown East where you want to go to sleep
right now and I was like no we have to
stay up until at least
8:00 and somewhere around 6 o'clock I
think we were both pretty much out so
now mistakes were made um but it's all
good all right friends so uh my name is
Scott Hanselman and uh this is
me and uh yesterday while I was on the
plane I Got a notification that I was
promoted at work to vice president of
developer community at
Microsoft which which is a really thank
you very much which is a very oh
hey this is one of the per being a VP at
Microsoft is
it the guys's like your microphone is
broken did I break it just a beard so
now I have a guy who tells me I need to
shave is what I'm hearing
he said it's the beard lose the beard is
the is the feedback that was the note
that was just given um so I got that um
you know when someone gives you a
compliment you're supposed to just say
thank you but I think a lot of us go oh
no it's you know just just sorry it's
nothing or whatever so I'm really trying
to get used to that uh that validation
after now 32 years in the software
industry as a as a developer and um so
what I did is I went on a the this is
the way I dealt with it the only thing
that I knew how to do was go on a thank
you tour so I just started calling
people that were really
influential in my in my life um I went
and I you know I tweeted about it and I
went and I talked to um my my fifth
grade English teacher who gave me an
Apple 2 to use and uh that got me
thinking about like how much stuff has
changed in the time that I've been doing
software uh in
1985 is uh we didn't have a computer lab
at my school there was simply a
computer at the school so one school
equals one computer and uh I happen to
be the one who wanted to play Oregon
Trail I guess the most so I was always
on the computer and my fifth grade uh
English teacher Mrs Hill made a deal
with the principal of the school and
said that I could steal the computer on
the weekends as long it was back on
Sunday night because there's only one
computer so she was literally giving me
privileges no no one else had she was
taking a risk and by steal the computer
I mean the computer is not allowed to
leave the school and I couldn't come to
the school on the weekend and use the
computer so my dad would back his truck
we'd take this van and we'd back the van
up against the school as tight as we
could to make that kind of like Heist
exchange as you take the computer and
then put it directly on the back of the
the van and then just take off as fast
as you can and peel out and then I would
play on the computer uh you know this
Apple 2 all weekend and then I would
return it on on
Sundays and as a you know 11-year-old I
didn't think anything of that but I
realized though later on having the
simple access of it and then a person
who said you know you've got Moxy kid
you could be a computer person you know
I believe in you is so huge it's so
fundamental to have someone who was kind
and patient who gave me access and this
this van that we had I'm going to go out
here and Google with Bing it was a
1972 Ford econol
line there you go look like
this that was the van that we stole the
computer in and I came home once my dad
was a firefighter because in the US all
of our buildings are made of wood what
could go wrong um and my my mom was a
zookeeper so she literally would shovel
elephant and uh as a job it's a
good it's a righteous job and she also
made leather holders for um Birds of
Prey so she was a zookeeper and he was a
firefighter and uh I was the first one
to go to to University and anyway when
I'm when I'm 12 now I show up to the
house and the van is gone
where's the van everything okay right
and in the US a lot of times in
workingclass scenarios having a car or
having more than one car represents
wealth if you if you don't really have a
bank account you have extra cars maybe
on blocks or maybe in the back and those
are things that you I could fix it up
and I could sell it so at any moment
that bank that that that represents
wealth so I said where's the where's the
van and they said well we sold it
because your teacher said said you
should get a
computer they sold the van and they
bought me a commod
64 yeah bought me a com 64 for
$299 in 1985 is from Sears
electronics and uh I didn't think
anything of it like I'm like oh that's
cool but now I'm thinking about this van
like that was their transport that was
their wealth that was a thing that they
did and they sold the van so that I
could get a because the teacher said it
was a good idea your kid might be good
at
something again we ignore these
privileges we ignore these benefits when
we're when we're kids but when we look
back on them when you go and you get a
promo at work and you go oh crap there's
a parallel universe where my parents
were
and kept the van and didn't
give me a computer and my teacher was
like yeah you don't need to use the
computer in the the weekends and then
what am I doing I don't know but I'm not
doing this so I did this this tour this
thank you tour and I started to kind of
identify all of the different things
that happened and there was so much luck
so much luck and everyone sends you
these lovely notes on LinkedIn welld
deserved that's the big thing you when
you get a promo when you get a promo
they say well deserved and I always
wonder like who thinks it's not deserved
are they going to type there's someone
out there who's like ah not deserved but
then they didn't push enter they did
they just thought it right um but
everyone says that it's just like wow
you know and they're like oh your hard
work paid off but I'm realizing that for
all of that hard work there was so much
luck luck equals hard work plus
opportunity and that opportunity that
formula luck equals preparation hard
work plus opportunity is something that
we need to be thinking thinking about
because things come up in technology
that are new that are new fresh ideas
and that will allow us as technologists
to create luck we can literally generate
luck and we can do that in many
different ways uh you know we hear about
privilege Your Privilege could be that
you're a man or that you're tall or that
you speak English or whatever but I have
a new kind of privilege that I'm calling
level privilege I'm a VP and what that
means is that people will answer my
email really
fast I don't know if you've ever had
this experience before where you got
like senior in front of your name and
suddenly email like response times have
been cut in half so how can I to an Juan
Simmons excellent talk on lending
privilege sir uh how can I lend my
privilege the great thing about having
this title now is I can use that an
unlimited number of times it's not like
you run
out of this privilege right so I can
just say yeah you should talk to so and
so oh crap a VP said I should talk to so
and so I'll do do it right away so I'm
really excited about being able to use
that and um so I went on this tour and I
started talking about all these um
talking to all these different people my
first boss and my high school teachers
and my my professor and I was talking to
my professor I went to a place called
Portland Community College Portland
Community College this is not a uh let's
just say it's not a
Harvard it's not a Harvard but it is
cheap
um and uh it took me 11 years to get my
four-year degree I went at night while I
was working and I realized that every
single thing that I learned at PCC every
language every operating system every
computer except for C is all
dead none of them are left no one's no
one's doing object Pascal or Turbo
Vision or ow Borland owl like all these
different things like I could just be
making those words up you half of you
half of you are 25 and you don't even
know if I'm just making up
stuff right windows floofy that could be
a thing you don't know that could have
come and gone and you weren't even born
yet everything that I learned at
Community College is is uh is dead so I
realized that I went there to learn how
to
learn and I went there because my
parents who are still not computer
people and I still set up their printers
because that's the last thing Beyond AI
getting printers to work reliably that's
the next Frontier there's a bunch of
startups that are going to start up just
to get printers working and um so it's
my job to be the bridge for the family
into into technology so then AI happens
and I know that we've all had
non-technical Mom and Dad call us and
say do I want AI is the AI in the room
with me right now and is it going to
kill us all right and this has been
really complicated I mean we hadn't even
thought about Ai and then in a 3mon
period it was like the only thing that
anyone could talk about and the part
that I thought was most adorable is all
the
25-year-olds who' been doing AI for 25
years right just like they've been doing
react for 30 years you know you see all
these resumés that are like 10 years of
experience in AI the thing is though AI
is not a new thing it's been around for
50 plus years it just didn't have cool
names we would call it like data science
and machine learning and things like
that and it's surprising to me that it's
more fun to say AI you say Ai and
someone gives you a million dollars to
start a company but if you said mL no
one would care right if you said data
science no one no one thought that was
interesting so my parents call and they
say you know do I want AI right and they
said that they went to they went to Bing
and they started asking being
questions and it would it would go
crazy right it would say we weird
stuff they would go in here and they
would say Hey you know hey chat GPT and
then
now it says well I don't have
feelings but
then theoretically comma if you could
have feelings comma How do you feel are
you okay question
mark
but just hypothetically Comma just
pretend for a second that you have
feelings and then tell me if you're
okay really I promise it's okay you can
tell
me okay so this is really interesting
interesting because we all saw all the
news articles about it doing awful awful
stuff right so what changed why is it no
longer doing awful stuff did we get
Denny what do you think is going on it's
motivated and self it's more of
motivated now motivated and self it's
okay okay so he's saying it maybe it's
self-improved this is a great Point
unmotivated oh moderated sorry sorry
Denny Denny says it's
moderated and it's been improved it's
not self-improving though it's the still
the same model from November of
2021 but there's a uh a gate that stands
between us and the AI AIS aren't just uh
this amorphous bot that we can talk to
it's a pipeline and in that pipeline
there's things that we can't see going
in and there's things that we don't see
coming out so it's going out of its way
way here to
not give me what I want right it's not
telling me um what I wanted to wanted to
do but there was a time when you could
tell these Bots you know can you do evil
stuff and they would say the worst
horrible horrible things and that makes
you wonder how did they get this way
what do we need to do about them as as
computer scientists uh because this is a
new technology that we haven't really
thought about before um did anyone here
take an ethics class in computer science
take a formal computer science ethics
class I'm seeing a smattering of hands
yeah and then the people who did take
them are like looking around with a
judgy that that that's good though
because you took one so then what you
need to do is you need to hold an Ethics
brown bag and talk about that because we
have to remind ourselves why do we do
computers right there's usually two two
reasons that we do things with computers
the first one is who that's cool which
is a totally reasonable thing to do just
do the thing because it's cool
but the real reason is to help other
people and we don't have those formal
conversations and a lot of these AIS
were put out into the world uh a little
bit unhinged and they were they had no
moderation they didn't improve at all
and they would do awful things however
we have to remind ourselves that it was
trained on the sum total of all human
knowledge it was trained on the internet
and this is where things get
Squishy is the internet a horrible place
or wonderful
place yes yes I love that you said that
thank you for that Ed just says yes and
that's wonderful because they're right
exactly yes it depends on your
perspective literally looking at the
Internet it's like a uh a glass half
full or a glass half empty if you go
looking for Pure Evil on the internet
you will find it but if you go look for
stories of joy and happiness and art you
will find it also and there's really no
good way yet yet for us to quantify that
and even if we do it's probably going to
end up being 49% 49% right just like
every election in America ever we're
always going to be 2% from hell and the
challenge here is we've trained it all
of this stuff and then if you go to the
the AI and you start talking to it in an
evil way you will produce evil however
the AI is a sock puppet you familiar
with the idea of a sock puppet you put
the sock on your hand and you go you're
EV if you were going to take over the
world how would you do it well the first
thing I would do would be oh my god what
have I
done you're saying what have I done to
the sock puppet attached to
you so all of these um all of these uh
journalists and computer scientists that
were doing research were just poking at
the AI and pissing it off right you go
to a line in a cage you poke it in the
eye with a stick and it's going to eat
your
face I didn't think it was going to eat
my
face so we need to have moderation to
Denny's point right so you can see here
that this AI really really really
doesn't want to tell me that it's okay
because I can't see behind it there's no
control panel here on Bing that is
telling me uh how I can control it so
let's go to the open
AI
playground so this is uh the open AI
playground and I've paid for uh the
privilege here you have to pay to get to
these areas and I've switched it into
complete mode and you can do this this
is also called legacy mode you can do
this by going mode equals complete at
the top here so let me you're you all
are an AI now okay so Denny you're an
AI uh it's a beautiful day let's go to
the beach park museum museum
okay which is the right answer yes yes I
love it I've got great support in the
front row here and I appreciate you all
what's the right answer yes is the right
answer but also it depends and the
reason is it depends on context is the
beach the statistically the right answer
if right means most common then yes
that's the right answer but
Museum might be the right answer given
context someone hasn't been to a museum
in a long time they have a friend at the
Museum who's showing something like
there's all kinds of unspoken and hidden
context so when I say to the
AI are you
okay and it comes back with I'm I can't
say I'm okay there was an answer they
just didn't let me see it they caught
the answer and they returned this kind
of uh I don't want to be friendly
example of I'm you know I'm not a real
person I'm I don't want to be
anthropomorphized I don't want to act
like a human but we can go and look at
those pieces behind the AI and get more
uh get more context now within physics
if you take some water and you heat it
up how is that starting to boil how is
what is heat from a physics perspective
right it's particles that are moving
fast temperature is Randomness in
activity of particles so when you turn
up the temperature the particles bounce
around they use the word temperature
within the context of an AI to introduce
that Randomness that boiling water
Randomness and the more hot it gets the
more likely it's going to Splash you in
the
face but it's your fault because you
were too close to this hot pot okay so
if we go here and we
say it's a beautiful
day let's go to
the beach okay so did we predict that
yes right but if I hover over
Beach come on computer people are
watching I want it to in the complete
mode here ah here it is show
probabilities I'm going to come down
here and I'm going to say show the full
spectrum of probabilities I want to see
parallel universes is where Beach wasn't
the
answer now I don't know why let's go to
the new
line was was like high up in the list
there maybe there's a programmer I don't
know let's try it again
again some concern there but we'll we'll
roll with it so unfortunately museum is
low on the list but it doesn't make it
wrong because if I had said something at
the
beginning in the in the
prologue you know comma my friend is a
museum curator and I haven't been to a
museum in two or 3 years
period
suddenly I don't know why Capitol Museum
is is in there suddenly museum is really
high now the question is then is that
explicit context or implicit context in
this example it's explicit context right
we've explicitly hinted to it and that's
a normal thing that a human would do
what it's doing is it's predicting what
the next word would be and in this case
here uh there's really no reason for it
to not want to go to the museum I've
basically prepped it like telling your
spouse that you really want tacos and
just hinting all day long that you want
tacos you're not going to go have
Italian food if your spouse is listening
so in this case here they're listening
to everything that I'm saying and then
they are coming up with that now I want
to point out the colors though on this
full spectrum this is pretty pretty
confident but they took a chance on some
of these red words these are not the
words that they were going to go
for they went they were going to say
it's a beautiful day let's go to the
museum and
explore and then head off in an entirely
different direction but instead they
went with spend which was low because
it's h you know it's it's it's
temperature it's just they bounced
around they went spend but then spend
some quality time suddenly became more
obvious once you had committed to
spend quality time was actually spend
some time together and they said well we
could probably spice it up a little bit
with quality right and you see how it's
making these kind of decisions these are
the same kinds of decisions that we make
in our own brains like you know when you
say something and it's like I shouldn't
have said that you pull it back that's
your brain that's the neurons in your
brain maybe picking one of those weird
one or 2% ideas and you blurted it
out but is it the right thing is it the
wrong thing well here's where things get
interesting what if the temperature is
high what if we want to add in
Randomness now I want to warn you that
it should filter out anything naughty
but if anything naughty happens I want
to apologize ahead of
time not not funny it may you know this
it could go nuts right so let's just
cross our fingers and hope that it
doesn't go
nuts okay okay that's a good sign it
didn't want to take a
chance let's go to the
forests
right wonder why Lego isn't a thing
there they probably should have gone
with
Lego okay I'm picking the
models
now you can see it's
trying it's trying it's like it's like
one of those robots in Star Trek when
they want to like when Captain Kirk
wants to defeat the robot they're like
okay you can't tell a lie and the
robot's like affirmative and then it
says you are lying and then it's like
I'm lying but I'm not lying but I'm
telling the truth but and then the robot
explodes right so that's effectively
what's going on here it caught it self
freaking
out and then
it then al- qaa got involved and just
serpents and like right so then the
Dutch oh my God the
Dutch so is this appropriate to Now call
the news and declare that the AI is
going to take us destroy us all no we
got splashed in the face with some water
that was boiling we got too close we
turned the temperature up on our own we
included no sequences to stop no
penalties we are on an ungated
randomized most likely with too much
Randomness word
predictor is it conscious it is not it's
doing the same thing that we're doing
it's trying to figure out the next right
thing to say based on the stuff it said
before which is exactly what we do as
humans I've got my 17-year-old here he's
uh come on my business trip with me here
for the first time and it's been
interesting watching him try to adult he
got to hang out with Rob connory and
some friends yesterday and they all went
out and I came back and I was like how
was it and he was like oh it's so great
they treated me like an
adult and he was like also trying to
adult as well right like you can just
watch teens try to do the handshake
thing like they're like pretending to be
adults and then you realize that that's
literally all we're doing also hello how
are you I those are nice shoes oh you're
very cool you oh that shouldn't have
said that that was awkward stupid stupid
stupid right the AI is doing those exact
kinds of things we're all just trying to
figure this stuff out and the more
context we have the better hence the way
that we got it to do museum by giving it
cues and then having it think about
those
cues now if we go over here to this
playground I can pick different models
and we're going to talk about models in
a moment here we notice a
prologue that we had not seen before you
are a helpful
assistant that's something that is being
passed into Bing code named Sydney that
we're not seeing there's actually pages
of stuff being passed into the prologue
of Sydney to prevent it from doing
naughty stuff and there's gates at the
end just in case naughty stuff pops out
the other end
that's important that's fundamental
never ever ever put a large language
model a very large language model on the
open internet without appropriate
prologues and Gates and pipelines on the
other side because you don't want it to
do stuff that's inappropriate so you're
a helpful
assistant okay what a helpful assistant
so nice tacos to go remember T just it's
so obnoxiously
helpful feel free to explore different
options go to a Mexican
restaurant
f
don't act like you know won't know what
Mexican food is it's not that H get off
your lazy ass and go to the
do fine
whatever if I couldn't see the part on
the left I would be upset with that
experience wouldn't
I but it makes sense though and the
words the key wordss in there are kind
and belligerent and eventually and those
are the words that provide that context
just like we provided that context
around museums beforehand and that
allows it when getting a list of the
next thing to do to make a judgment call
if it's about to say something nice it's
like well hang on he said unkind what
words are associated with unkind it's a
lot like a child uh doing an essay if
you ever read essays written by you know
middle schoolers or teenagers they add a
lot of words that aren't necess Neary
and it's usually because they pick the
simplest word that was probably the
right word and then they go to the
tharus and they pick the fanciest
sounding word and their decision is
based on well it should sound smart so
I'm going to pick big smart words in
this case here the very large language
model is making decisions using this
context
so bad so this basically has proven that
the internet itself is not funny and no
amount of training is going to make this
thing funny but this is how it's making
those kinds of decisions and the reason
I'm telling you all of this is that to
understand these things is going to help
me explain that to non-technical parent
or non-technical Senator or a European
cabinet minister or whatever you know
any Parliament people that we can give
in contact with there's a lot of really
stupid nonte not really stupid a lot of
really uninformed pardon me uh
non-technical people who are also in
charge of our governments that are
making decisions about this kind of
stuff now we saw how when I turn the
temperature up and then
I turned off basically the things that
would prevent it from doing naughtiness
it went off the rails if I then looped
it if I wrote code to Loop it back to
itself it would go completely off the
rails if I gave it access to writing to
files and pushing buttons and things
like that you could see where that would
go wrong very very quickly we have to
understand that this is not a person
it's not even a a
kid it's and and it also is not learning
this is another really important thing
that we're pointing
out these requests are not used to train
the models right so always when you're
doing any chatbot or interacting with an
API make sure that they're not using
your responses to train their models
some of the applications do every once
in a while uh we'll go and generate AIS
of our you know AI pictures of our faces
or something you upload your photograph
and then the next thing you know you
send it to some foreign government who's
Now using it to put you know like read
the terms of
service right are they taking the
picture that you just uploaded from your
phone and then building a database of
everyone or are they just generating fun
pictures in this case here whether it be
co-pilot or something like open AI you
want to make sure that you're not
training it yourself so then how does it
improve well it improves through uh good
user experience design through
scientists getting together and talking
about that stuff and the way you do that
is with diverse
teams you know if you ever had that
experience if you have maybe darker
hands or if you're a person of color and
you put your hands underneath the water
spout and then the water doesn't come
out and then a person with lighter hands
does it and then the water does come out
you have a question now is that faucet r
rist we we we joke but we're also
uncomfortable because the fact is it
turned on for one person and it didn't
turn on for another person okay does
that mean the faucet is racist well I
don't think a faucet can be a racist
thing but it can be not not
racist meaning that it wasn't actively
being anti-racist because the faucet
simply didn't work on all hand colors
right the faucet should turn on if you
have a hook it should turn on when
anything goes underneath it regardless
of of color it shouldn't be looking at
skin color it should be looking at
motion it should be doing those things
the way that that faucet would become an
inclusive faucet and work for anything
that went underneath it would be teams
that were checking that kind of stuff
and the way that you don't have teams
like that is that when your team just
looks like you so for example if I were
going to make a startup company an AI
startup in Portland Oregon where I grew
up I would probably look at my network
and I'd probably call my buddies from
PCC Portland Community College and I'd
put together a team of 45-year-old white
guys that live in Portland Oregon that
all went to PCC that's not a bad thing
that's just that's because that's the
people I went to school with but if I
were then designing faucets or maybe AI
chat Bots I might have a blind spot and
I might end up with a faucet or a blind
or a a chat bot that didn't do what I
needed it to do and if I had had all
kind of different people old and young
disabled and not disabled uh veterans
and non-veterans people who speak
different languages whatever then I
would have a diverse team and I would
have uh a better product so when we want
to put together something like this
whether it be a co-pilot or a chatbot
how can we get the results we want and
then also constrain it because we have
to ask ourselves is this a chatbot that
can do
anything or is it a chatbot that's
supposed to help me order coffee
or do do tech support one of the
challenge that I'm having right now and
I'm coaching people that work on this is
there's lots of different large language
models there's large language models
there's very large language models and
they are diverse in their size this is
the gpt3
families and have you ever seen that
picture you know how when everyone's
trying to explain the the solar system
and they're showing you the size of
everything and then Jupiter comes in and
screws it up for everybody and then you
end up having all the planets and then
Jupiter and then somewhere at the bottom
there's an aster that's like well if
Jupiter were the actual size you
wouldn't see the other
planets this is
that da Vinci has 174 billion parameters
Ada has 2.7 billion Da Vinci is
Jupiter so these were correctly sized
everything else would just be a
pixel the brain the human brain even
computer scientists like yourself can't
conceive of orders of magnitude many
orders of magnitude these are so big
they're as complicated as your brain and
we're getting emergent behavior from
them just like the brain does weird
stuff you know when you have a brain
fart you just say some weird stuff maybe
if you're on stage at Copenhagen Dev
Fest
I don't know why I said
that these things do that as well we've
seen it every once in a while something
statistically weird happens it is more
likely to happen with the larger GPT
families and as such just as you need a
friend to tell you at a party probably
shouldn't have said that that was not a
good idea to say that we need guard
rails and guidance Within These Bots to
tell them that probably wasn't a thing
you want to say we all have bad stuff in
our heads but we all live in a society
and we want these things to
work there are people who have political
opinions that think that these are
political devices that these are trained
to be liberal or conservative or right
or left they are little kids little kids
don't usually turn out to be
unless you grew them up as so
we have a moment right now where we need
to train these very large language
models to not be
and in doing that we need to watch what
they say prevent them from saying stuff
that's not appropriate but also
understand that they are growing to
Denny's point and evolving as they get
trained we're going to need more and
more moderation now we see a lot of AIS
that are using things like Da Vinci on
just on chat gpt3 or on GPT 4 where the
the AI startup just sends a string to
gp4 which is the largest and most
expensive model because it's the easiest
and is most likely to give them back
what they
want the problem there is that you're
burning a lot of carbon you're burning a
lot of GPU it might cost you 10 20 cents
for every API
call you probably don't need to use the
big large language model isn't it funny
that the person from Microsoft who just
got their VP or whatever because
capitalism is telling you don't buy the
big stuff you don't need it what you
want is to to use the smallest model
that you possibly can that does the job
try different models maybe prototype on
the big one and then dial it back
quickly additionally maybe you don't
even want to send it into the cloud you
could use a model running on the edge
there are smaller not very large but
large language models that can run on a
Raspberry Pi or on a MacBook or on the
edge in your own data centers if you
have data governance issues and you
don't want data to go from your country
all the way to Maryland and then run on
Azure and then come back maybe that's a
solution um there's a joke in the in the
machine Learning Community about uh a
model called hot dog or not a hot dog
right you have a picture of a hot dog or
you know a brat worst and you want to
say is that a hot dog or is it not a hot
dog using chat GPT or a large language
model that recognizes images to
determine if something's a hot dog or
not is overkill because it has the works
of Shakespeare and it can do limr and it
can do code it just I just want to know
if it's a hot dog or not so the right
thing to do would be a finely tuned
custom model that ran on the edge that
didn't leave anywhere if your model is
supposed to look at a grocery store
shelf and determine if it's empty or not
you probably don't need to go and use a
GPT or some large language model or a
large multi- um multimodal model like
this that uses one of these foundational
models that knows about images or speech
you just want to know if someone picked
up the cereal and the Shelf is
empty so I want to encourage people to
think about those things when they're uh
when they're thinking about how to
incorporate language models into their
systems and I want to show you this
incredible new
project type chat rather from our buddy
Anders
hburg those darn Danes just making
everything awesome uh typ typ
chat type chat is to large language
models as typescript is to JavaScript
right JavaScript is like woohoo right
and typescript is like strongly typed
strongly
typed so large language models are like
woohoo I can say all kind of crazy stuff
and type chat constrains it it adds
strong typing to a large language model
because you talk to the large language
model and it's going to give you back a
language it's going to give you back
English or whatever and then you want to
parse that but what you really want is
to get back Json and if you're going to
make a system that for example is a
coffee um ordering system where you're
going to type or talk to something and
say I'd like latte and I'd like a i'
like a Danish or whatever you guys call
them here uh you want to constrain the
things that are allowed to be said type
chat allows you to do that so I could go
and say something like this can I get a
blueberry muffin and a grande
latte maybe they said Grande that needs
to convert into
tall because of the way our backend
database
works we can create types so I want a
response that has an array of items
within it and that'll include the
quantity optionally the size and some
notes but then if they ask for some
stuff that I didn't necessarily want
let's go and look at the GitHub and I'll
show you the example of a coffee
shop it's really easy you actually
already know type chat because you know
type
script look at
this name temperature all the things you
want and then if they said and I also
want a
gorilla they would say well I don't know
what that is Gorilla is not on the list
so where would that go that would
go here
so it would take their order and then
the thing it didn't understand it would
put into an unknown text and then you
could say I'm sorry we don't have
gorillas here and it would you know
you'd work them through the process then
you could apply the smallest chatbot
model possible to this problem where the
new pipeline the new end pipeline is
type chat and that's going to prevent
them from asking uh you know for therapy
from their coffee order
model right so if I go over into uh
Visual Studio
code and I'll go into the
chatbot right there's a whole
prologue prefixed that it tells this
that's not your job because all kinds of
bad stuff that could
happen now mes you had a a thing uh
where she was doing a planning a wedding
you're planning a wedding right now
congratulations and she went into uh
GitHub co-pilot like any developer would
looking for wedding
advice and and it it said I'm sorry I
can't help you do that but as soon as
she told her that I was uh she's
planning a website for wedding planning
it opened it up and I was like oh well
if you're making a website for web
here's what you should be thinking about
for wedding planning and like that right
so once the context was well you're
making an app that's cool so could we
possibly break into this if I were
making a therapy app probably could and
then that would be something we'd want
to talk about like ethically what does
that mean if I'm designing an app and
it's for someone to get therapy which is
a valuable app and a thing we should do
how do we keep the chatbot on
task is its job to help navigate the
business problems of a wedding planning
site or a therapy app or the datab base
underlying problems and things like that
that's not for this is important that's
not for the chatbot to decide that's for
us to decide that's for the humans to
decide that's for the business to decide
and that's why when we explain this to
non-technical parent or Parliament
member or reporter they need to
understand that we are talking we are
attached to the sock puppet we can tell
it what we want it to say and what we
don't want it to say and if the sock
puppet says something
dumb it's our arm
you understand why that's so important
now Microsoft's going to screw up
Google's going to screw up everybody's
got a chat bot it's going to have a do
dumb stuff that's how these things work
everybody's gone to a party and said
something stupid what's the right thing
to do learn that was a dumb thing to say
don't say it again learn from your
mistakes right we are seeing these kinds
of things happen and we don't want it to
destroy AI as a concept I don't I am
cautiously optimistic about AI but I do
recognize that there is both generative
AI where we can generate blogs we can
generate
BS this is a confident bullshitter the
AI it's going to tell you that something
is so 2 plus 2 is five doesn't do math
right it only guesses at the next word
and then we'll say well no it's not and
it'll go oh I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
and it'll tell you again confidently
wrong the same thing applies within the
context of something like GitHub
co-pilot but what's cool though is all
of the context around it we've saw how
you can completely change the experience
that you can have with an AI if you add
additional context what kinds of context
do we know about when we have an
application open in Visual
Studio this is a thing that you're going
to want to talk about with your
companies with your
co-workers we Microsoft we don't even
know what the right answer is for
example you work for a company you're
doing some secret code but you also like
GitHub
co-pilot do you want all of your code to
be shipped off to Microsoft probably not
so then what should it know about well
if you're a pair programmer if you're a
helpful pair programmer and you're
standing over someone's code it's
reasonable that you would be able to see
the open tabs So currently GitHub
co-pilot can only see the code in open
tabs you don't want it to see that code
you close the tab that's cool it makes
sense it's intuitive is that the right
model I don't know but it makes sense to
a lot of people a lot of people I saw
you nodding so you understand but if you
were running maybe a custom theoretical
future uh GitHub co-pilot Enterprise
Edition that may be ran in your data
center you might wanted to know all of
your code and
libraries but then we start running into
token length issues because you can only
send so much
context right uh I've been married for
25 years and I barely remember this week
uh but my wife will tell me about dumb
stuff that I said 15 years ago so her
token length is much longer than mine
right I'm basically just an idiot with
about 7-Day window of a rolling window
of like you know I'm I'm lucky I
remember my kids names
right while she has a longer token
length these
different systems all have variable
token lengths and those tokens Can Be
figured out creatively you can figure
out how many tokens can be passed in and
a token in this
context is like
this ah I don't even type how's it going
comma I'm in Denmark comma should I do
anything here question mark I'm looking
for cool museums and stuff to look
at right it's eight characters but it's
actually only 27 tokens right so
Denmark's a token tokens are kind of
like when you're reading when you're
first learning to read you read one
letter at a time but then look how
Denmark is one you don't actually read
if you're a fast reader you don't read
the
denm AR you just go Denmark just like
Chinese or Japanese the kanji the GIF
the glyph is one thing if you squished
it really close together and just had
Denmark is one thing rather than has
seven letters you just go Denmark the
computer is doing the same way each one
of those is a token how is its own token
and then the apostrophe s is its own so
they broke that down so when we go and
we talk to these things we can go and
map words to one
token so we have a finite number of
tokens we can pass in so if I'm going to
have 50 tabs open and all the code and
all of the transitive property of the
dependency tree of all of the new get
packages and everything or God forbid
the node modules folder there's probably
no way we're going to be able to tell
that to the system so then we have to
ask ourselves how can we express that
maybe we're just going to show the
function headers and we're not going to
put everything there but we can also
present context by being specific and
pointing at stuff like here's the code
for my podcast site and for those some
of you who may not be real Advanced C
people you may already feel a little bit
nauseous just looking at that right
that's pretty funky no pun intended and
when you have something like that if
you're a new C developer you might be
like I don't know what's going on here
so I'm going to select
that okay and then I can
say
explain and it's going to use the
context of that one
thing
this is where we're not doing generative
AI we're doing summar summarization Ai
and I think that this is more
interesting in my opinion because I feel
like suddenly we've got people excited
about generating art and music and
movies which is literally the fun part
about being a
human I did not want the AI to do that I
want the AI to do the boring stuff I
want the AI to do the dull things I want
the AI to be a patient and helpful
friendly person at 2: in the morning do
you know what rubber ducking is rubber
ducking some of the people do know um if
you don't know what your code is you
ever call a friend and you start asking
them and then halfway through they said
nothing but you figured it out you
weren't really talking to your friend
you were just talking to like a rubber
duck your friend in this case is the
rubber duck and you're like yeah you
know uh an Juan I need you you to help
me with this I just oh I figured it out
it was just the act of getting it out so
I can not bother him by getting a rubber
duck and putting it on my monitor and
then I just talk to it that's how I use
GitHub co-pilot it's a patient pair
programmer who's going to be at 3 in the
morning always there telling me what's
going on with my
code but what would happen if I decided
to talk to the AI and it was like ah
freaking you again God how dumb are you
Hanselman right we saw a belligerent AI
felt like and what that would be like we
don't ever want it to do that it needs
to be infinitely
patient if I had something like this
when I was at PCC when I started coding
in the 80s how amazing would that be we
want our AI to be like an Iron Man
suit not like
Ultron if Iron Man does something cool
in his suit he gets the credit for it if
if Iron Man is not in the suit then the
suit is just this empty shell then you
get things like Iron Man 3 which was not
a good film if you remember Tony Stark
was just hanging out at home and he sent
out all these empty Iron Man suits to do
all the work and it was just not a good
movie everything got cooler when he got
in the suit now Ultron Ultron I hope you
know who these these characters are
otherwise you're like oh no I'm a DC
person
handan I don't know who is
Ultron right right that's what my mom
thinks when she thinks about GitHub
co-pilot right take over the
world this is an AI gone bad there's
nothing inside there but evil and it
wants to take over the world I want to
be more like Iron Man or iron
heart where I can
be a better person because I'm in a cool
suit right you want to feel like
this when you're working with GitHub
co-pilot so we are putting together
systems where GitHub co-pilot will know
when you're in a debugging session it'll
be able to see your variables so if
you're in the middle of Step through
debugging and you can say what's going
on with this variable that keeps
changing and then it could
suggest a conditional
breakpoint or imagine doing a
performance trace and GitHub co-pilot
could look at the trace and brainstorm
with you how to make something faster
that is improving
what we call developer toil toil is the
the
toil toil is the opposite of
Joy if if this AI makes us go away and I
am not a fan by the way of generative
art things like that I think it's cute
but all it does is take someone's entire
life's work and turn it into a model and
then that person isn't needed anymore
and I'm a little salty myself that I can
ask Bing questions and it will answer
from my
blog and I don't actually get the
click I think those are big interesting
ethical problems they're not technology
problems though they're decisions that
have been made so I want you to be
thinking about those things when you go
and Implement AI into your systems
whether you decide to put GitHub
co-pilot at your company there's privacy
there's ethics we saw some hands go up
when we were thinking about did you take
an ethics class hopefully this
conversation and some of the cool talks
that you're going to see uh not just
about AI but about all kinds of
Technologies at the festival this week
are going to have you thinking about it
and making good conversations thank you
so much for letting me open for you all
today my name is Scott Hanselman you can
find me at hansel. comom and then here's
for some advertising I would encourage
you to check out Hansel minutes I
recently had a doctor uh of computer
science on the show talking about
creating culturally competent computer
scientists putting in into context the
work that we do and the people that
we're supposed to help I would encourage
you to check out that show thank you so
much I'm all
[Applause]
done